[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to film and
pendant presents i'm rachel blemer
director of events for film independent
before we get started with today's very
exciting q a i have to give some praise
to our loyal supporters our incredible
lead sponsor the hollywood foreign press
association and our screening partner
vision media
i'm really honored today to introduce
our guest moderator um
there's so much we can say about her
just she's having this summer of natalie
morales i mean we just we're such big
fans of your work here at home
independent with plan b
and um i just uh i'm so excited this is
happening so i'm gonna let natalie take
it from here my fellow miamian uh
director and actress um she is going to
be speaking all things roy de moreno and
i will leave you all to it thank you so
much for being here thank you rachel i'm
so excited to be here with mattiem and
brent and rita um i'm not usually the
person doing the interviews i'm not very
good at this so forgive me uh there's a
whole other natalie morales who does
this usually but i think uh what does
qualify me is that i'm a lifelong
admirer of rita's work
i'm a big fan of this movie i'm a latina
i'm an actor i'm a writer i'm a director
i have been qualified yes
i am i've been navigating this town for
the last 15 years and i've always been
so interested in hollywood history and
even more specifically the history of
someone so uniquely trailblazing as rita
is so forgive me if i fangirl a little
bit throughout this interview but i am i
am pretty excited
hello cutie
she comes with history emmy grammy oscar
and tony i was really drawn to her she
made me feel like women could do
anything because she did she was a
ladina like me
she just brings such authority and such
honesty to whatever she's playing some
people might view rita moreto as the
embodiment of the american dream at the
age of 16 years old she was the sole
breadwinner for her family little puerto
rican girl whom nobody thought much of
at mgm with a contract
that's a lot of work at 87 with a hit
show and a movie in the works it's a
remake of west side story with latino
actors in the lead role
if we thought there was no place for us
in this world of the arts that we wanted
to get into we could look up and see
rita and say okay well she could do it
how close can i get
so rita what went through your mind when
the idea of a documentary about you was
presented to you
not a lot
okay i i'm prone to things like that i
just thought ah
well i am it took almost a year right
brent brent miller is our co-producer
and actually it was his idea so he's
more than just a co-producer
and i just i just wasn't really sure
that
that i had a lot to contribute
and uh you know now i've seen the film
several times and i say to myself man
what a life this is
really i'm very impressed with this life
you should be but you know but what's
what's cuckoo about it is that it's you
know you don't think of yourself if
someone came to you natalie and said we
want to do this
and i don't know how you would react but
the the it seems to me that the normal
reaction is well you know i just haven't
lived my life from one
of them
and then you see it put together by a
mind and i'm thinking now of this
beautiful woman
mariam
who's our director
and i think
how did i get so lucky i think it's a
wonderful
wonderful and truthful
and authentic
and imaginative and creative
piece of work as a documentary i think
it's quite amazing
and uh i'm i'm just so happy that it
happened that's not an answer to your
question but i always do that i have
long no i
i never say yes or no i have long
answers it was it was i wanted that long
answer i want i i imag i imagine that i
imagine that it must be very strange to
have someone say i want to make a
documentary about your life but it's
like when you go through old pictures
and old videos you realize you've lived
100 lives and and you're like wow
this is just crazy so okay so brandon
mariam take me through the origins of
making this movie how did you get
involved how did how did you come
together how did this all happen
it's brent's fault
yeah it was my fault and it was rita's
fault for living the life that she's
lived um and i i got to i was fortunate
to read her her memoir and then i
listened to it in her words uh one day
when i was heading up the coast
and i was shocked that no one had had
done her story before and i asked her i
said listen your story is told you've
done it it's in your words it's going to
live forever do you mind if we take a
stab and and and show your story on the
big screen um and then she said it took
some time but we were working together
on on a show called one day at a time
which also is how mariam and i know
because thank you uh because her son or
her grandson rita's grandson in the in
the show is mariam's real son marcel
ruiz
oh it was um you know it was literally
all in the family in a sense that when
when mariam heard that we were looking
to make a film and rita had accepted our
offer to make a film she knew that we
were also looking for a latinx woman um
and if we could find someone that was
puerto rican all the better uh so mariam
asked if she could submit you know her
interpretation of what she would do her
treatment of the film and we took off
everybody's name on these treatments and
then went through them blindly and hers
was the best it just it rose to the top
and
uh as i've said before we've had no
reason to regret it
i think i had the advantage that
because i was on on a set um
previous to knowing that we were going
to do this documentary and i was
observing rita who i also admire all my
life
um
because i was there as a mother
in that day right
right i was able to
observe rita from a different
perspective than
anybody would have the opportunity to
observe her um so i was there behind the
scenes watching her
drive to set being there without makeup
rehearsing and just being herself so
i think that gave me the opportunity to
to come up with an idea um
from from what i had seen um from that
other point of view
so when i reached out to brent i
remember that we didn't know each other
he only knew me as
marcel's mom
i said hey brent i'm i this is what i do
i do documentaries for living and i
would love
to be able to be considered for this so
um i had the opportunity to do that to
be able to to see something that no
maybe others didn't know about her
but i also um
wanted to bring that um
that paper doll um the idea of the paper
doll which is something that rita really
liked and i love that conceit
that's what um
that's how i guess i won
the bottle of everybody else
i love that it was uh literally and
figuratively all in the family that's
that's such a great detail
of the whole thing how did the
how did the whole uh how long did the
whole thing take to shoot from the
beginning of rita agreeing to it to the
end and how did the actual production go
we're still working on it
[Laughter]
it never ends no we we started um about
four years ago so it's it's really been
a journey and our goal was to
we we you know no one expected the
pandemic obviously but we did um
strategically talk about wanting to to
have our world premiere at sundance with
the hope that we would we would have a
theatrical release over the summer and
then ultimately would air on american
masters on pbs in the fall and then we
just you know it's an embarrassment of
riches that it happened to also coincide
with west side stories premiere which as
you know is going to be also in december
so
you know the stars align when they align
and and uh unfortunately you know i
think they they they're they always seem
to align for for rita
well that's not true i shouldn't say i i
think when they when it's time for them
that we're true there wouldn't be a
documentary
yeah everything was perfect right well
that's what i mean i don't mean that
perfect in a sense but i think when it's
time for them to align they do align in
a really meaningful way
i think
from what i've learned i i mean from
what i learned watching the documentary
that is that is my perception of it as
well i read i read rita that you really
wanted west side story to come out
before your 90th birthday and it's
coming out the day before is that right
is that crazy
because well you know we had to cancel
the first opening so really
west side story is like almost three
years old yeah
and uh
and
by that time i was calling steven
spielberg and say stephen
i'm gonna be 90 for pete's sake
but you know he was trying to he did not
under any circumstances
want this film to be streamed yeah yeah
be in theaters because it belongs on a
big screen yes really have to see it on
the big screen oh boy oh boy
your birthday is the same day as my
mom's birthday so it's december 11th yes
december 11th how old is your mom don't
tell me unless she
my mom she's going to be 70 this year
a child
child she has her whole life ahead of
her okay so rita did you have
any reservations about having it like
once you accepted okay i'm going to do a
documentary were you like
and i want you to talk about this or
what if they paint me in this light or i
don't want you to film me doing this
what a good question because in fact i
made a promise to myself that
if i was going to do this i was going to
be as honest as possible
i mean if i've left things out it's
certainly not on purpose it's just
i don't recall
and uh
my my objective
was to answer the questions i was being
asked
and answer them as honestly as i could
and i think you can see that definitely
when mariam asks me in a certain very
uh delicate and sometimes touchy
questions
and uh sometimes it was
i didn't have a hard time answering most
of the time but once in a while
particularly with the questions about my
husband and my marriage right
that wasn't so easy because it's so it's
so easy really to uh
we did not have a happy marriage
i mean seven years and then from then on
it became 44 years
and i was very unhappy much of that time
and uh
so it's easy to make the fella feel bad
yeah you're talking about it with whom
you had this long relationship
and you know people of course went well
why didn't you leave oh well
see the documentary
but um
other than that
i knew that i had to answer
whatever i was asked there were no
planned questions on my part i had no
idea
what marianne was going to ask but
what's interesting that she's said since
then
and you might want to ask her about this
is that she was going through a divorce
at the time
and
marcel's daddy and she
were getting
split up
and i think uh she has some interesting
things to say about how my story
affected
what was happening with her
yeah yeah
i i think that that i mean so much of
this this movie
in watching it i don't know if it's
because i'm a woman or a latina or just
a person but i can see your
your point of view and rita's and i can
see
how how her life is
unique and also extremely relatable in
so many different small areas and you
kind of feel like
like wow
part of that honesty that you're talking
about rita was so beautiful and
important to see because it felt like
you were like what is the point of
hiding any of this what is the point of
of keeping anything
what's the point of doing it then right
exactly talking about my life are we
talking about my life as a fiction right
right so miranda do you want to talk
about that i don't wanna i don't wanna
put you on the spot but
no actually um we we all talked about it
about wanting to do a documentary that
wasn't just a show reel of rita's career
but something that we could all relate
and that was the idea behind it when
when i
when i was able to see rita on a set
um without makeup driving to set all of
that it that's rita the human being and
that's why i wanted everyone to be able
to experience to to be able to relate to
her to be able to say oh my god this is
an amazing woman but i can relate
because we all go through the same
things and
as much as i got to know her and to read
about her i i was able to relate so much
with
my own experiences and i realized that
it's not only mine but
almost every woman and especially if
you're a latina so i really wanted
to be able for everyone to connect with
that to be able to say oh my god i felt
that way before
and
so
i guess my questions came from
my own
from what i was feeling or i'm going
through because i know that if i was
going through that and feeling that
i wasn't the only one um there's
obviously other people going through
that and feeling the same way
i realized that there were things that i
was going through
at my time 50 years after
that she went through and
sometimes that made me feel
more um calm in a way because it was
like okay i'm not here alone this is not
happening to me
and i realized that it's not only to
women mostly to women but i've talked to
many men also that feel
also relatable to to rita's stories and
and that i think it's
what we wanted to accomplish that's
wonderful too that it's a surprising
amount of men are very moved as a matter
of fact so they should buy this
documentary
and uh they actually brent maybe you can
uh
you can uh uh just add some things about
what men
feel when they watch this i was
surprised
i was very pleasantly surprised to say
the least well i was walking my dog in
in the neighborhood the other day and
one of the guys had
i had conversation with an older man
who's by in his early 70s and uh
he had known that i had we had talked
about that this movie was coming out and
he couldn't wait to see it he's a big
fan of yours he's originally from ohio
and i saw him just the other night over
the weekend and he came out
and was just over the moon
about the film in general and how much
he loved it but he got emotional when he
talked about it because he said i never
knew that side of her story and i feel
so bad
as a man that she went through all that
she went through which i thought was
really
i mean that answers your question right
there he he and he's he's a straight man
with kids and the whole nine yards but
he felt bad he felt like he just felt
bad for you and that he wanted to be a
gentleman
uh that you didn't
have so often in those early days
oh that's lovely thank you so much for
relating that well you got emotional
really emotional yeah
wow it is very emotional because you
you're somebody rita that we've we've
seen our whole lives and then to see
this other side of you that we didn't
know when you were
silently suffering is it is emotional
you i i don't i mean i'm sure you know
this i'm sure you've been told this a
million times but you you feel very much
like somebody we all know and love even
if i we've never met you
so
i promise an appropriate reaction but i
think i think what's interesting also
about the reactions is that
people uh tend to see
the you they want to see
right on film on television as a
as a guest on a talk show and they they
they just kind of relate to you in that
way so that when someone like myself who
is vivacious and has a sense of humor
and is raucous even uh that's what
people
think
they like about me so much and then you
see this this documentary which i'm
making it sound like it's like a door
it's not it has lots of humor too but uh
it surprises them
and i i'm thinking
well
i suppose so because i've always put up
such a good front
i mean the day before i took those pills
hoping that i would
no longer be
i was laughing and carrying on with
friends and you know nobody had a clue
because i'm so good at that
yeah
so it's kind of
it's kind of wonderful that people
see the side of this
uh this allegre
energetic woman i'm all of those things
too
but i'm also the other
yeah
speaking of the things that we present
to
the world and to other people i i want
to ask you this on a personal level
because it's something that i've kind of
discovered this year
uh
on my own in my own career is that i
want to ask you about your relationship
with latinidad and like what it means to
be a latina to you in this business
specifically because
you're both lauded for it and punished
for it your whole life and and that is
something that i went through
as well in in in my recent career where
i i felt
you know there was a time where i was
like i can't wear red to any auditions
because i'll look too latina and i can't
you know what i mean like i can't wear
hoop earrings i can't i can't do certain
things because i still want to be
palatable and get this job so i'm the
you know a palatable version of a latina
and and i'm only what i'm sorry go ahead
go ahead no i was just gonna say that
only recently
did i realize hey what [ __ ] that is
and b also what what uh i mean i'm not
necessarily entirely blaming myself for
having that thought i was trying to
succeed in this business and i was
trying to
get work and get roles and do things
that that you know i didn't feel were
i think you really laid the
this movie really discusses it a lot but
you laid the path for like
how horrible it is to be stereotyped so
often and put into these stereotypical
roles and i really fought against not
doing that in my career whenever i could
but the other side of that is rejecting
this part of myself that is that it does
like to wear red and does like to have
hoop earrings and is a latina and does
speak spanish and only in the last few
years that i really realized like
i think i can i don't care if i'm
palatable to people and i think just by
being myself i can be
what i want to be in this town so i
would love to ask you what
i mean i i imagine that your thoughts on
that changed all throughout your career
but i would like to ask you to elaborate
on that if you have any thoughts
uh
first of all that's that's very touching
what you just said it's very moving
and uh
it only reminds me of how often
latino women go through this
not that latino men don't they do i know
a wonderful
puerto rican actor named armando riesco
who still has trouble
who still has trouble because he doesn't
look
latino
of course bizarre you don't either for
that matter
well ambitiously ethnic is what i have
you don't fit the the cliche right
latina looks like i look more like a
latina than you do in that sense and my
manner also was very you know all of
that kind of cliche stuff
but i mean what what is your question
what do you want to know
i i want to know
what your relationship with that was in
your life like if you ever you know
being in hollywood and being
only cast as as
the ethnic person in something for so
long did it make you go listen my
english is perfect i can play any role
you want i can dye my hair blonde i
don't have to be this ethnic person all
the time and did it make you did you
ever have a a a relationship where you
rejected it or had a hard time with that
of how you were being perceived and
pigeonholed i couldn't afford to reject
terribly much i was really helping my
mom
and i had a little baby brother step
brother half brother i mean
and
it was very little that i could turn
down because i had to pay the rent and
help my mom
so it wasn't a question i mean i've been
asked so often well you know how do you
pick your own pick
right what was i offered right pay any
kind of money
yeah okay i'll do it
and you know the heartbreaking part of
it was that it was always these conchita
lolita
people
or uh uh east indian young women or
american indian i literally have a
picture of me with a band across my my
face and my head i mean and a feather
literally doing that
playing an american in dinner
and i'll tell you a heartbreaking story
i had read a script
because now and then our agents would
send scripts out to the actors and just
say this is kind of interesting what do
you think and are you interested in our
submitting you for a part in this
and i remember seeing the script and i
thought oh i would be really good in
this i just know i would be good in this
so i called my agent and this is during
a time when i was having a really
difficult time as opposed to the other
times when i was having a really
difficult time
and and uh
and i said to my agent oh i would love
to try out for this can you call the
director or whoever is seeing actors and
ask them uh to make an appointment to
see me and i will be happy to read them
you know scenes
uh of my character
uh in the movie and he said i absolutely
will
and
i was brokenhearted because the agent
said they won't see you
and i said why not he said well
then you're rita moreno
you know and i said
no what do you mean
he said you're latina i mean they
weren't even using that word then i
think right punish
right spanish
but do you can you imagine
can you even begin to imagine how
frustrating and heartbreaking it is
when you ask somebody
give me a chance let me show you what i
can do
that doesn't mean i would have gotten
the part but at least i would have
gotten the respect
of the people who were making this film
they wouldn't even see me for that
specific reason
and you just literally go home and cry
and then you get so angry
it was horrible
and it still happens
what
unfortunately that still happens today
and that's why i think it's relatable to
to to hear your stories 50 years ago and
we can all continue to relate to that
yeah it's i mean it's definitely
happened to me i had a similar story
where i had an audition to play you know
the best friend of the lead character
and the best friend was like this mousy
little girl and the lead character was
like this vivacious like strong person
and i was like i went to the casting
director i was like i have both parts
prepared can i read both for you
and they were so upset they banned me
from their office uh
what yes are you serious
yes wait a minute they actually said you
may now leave without they never they
told my manager that i disrespected them
in front of the producers and that uh
that i am not allowed to come back just
because i had i said i i have the part
you asked for me prepared but i also
think i would be great in this role i
have them both prepared can i please
read them to you and the producers were
like sure and then never again so yes it
still happens it still happens oh that
is
yeah infuriating and heartbreaking it is
when we get by we get by
um i have a question for you
and you know what's really tough about
that you then
when you have so many and i had so many
of those experiences what's tough
about that
kind of life
is not to turn into a stone
angry raging person yes
and i always advise young people be
careful of your rage
because it will only weaken you
that's all
it's it you know rage by its own nature
means that you're frustrated right rage
is different from anger and rage is is a
frustrated emotion
and i tell young people constantly don't
let that guide your life because you are
really screwed then and you're doing it
to yourself
it's great advice
very good advice i want to ask mary
mariam and brent what did you learn from
rita when making this oops
wow um
a lot
i will something that i always say that
i learned from her was
therapy
um the
how important that is
if you don't want to become someone
bitter
and
frustrated about everything that you can
offer and want to do and aren't able to
because you don't you're not allowed or
you don't get the opportunity so
therapy is something that i didn't know
about her and that i think is what
made her
be the person she is today the happy
person she is today
um
yeah that i would say oh i i just think
psychotherapy is so important of course
to be honest you have to be very lucky
and get the right doctor
and i did i was very lucky i mean we all
know the terrible stories about people
going into therapy and
being influenced in some terrible way
so you do have to have some sense of
judgment as to
when you interview the doctor because
that's what you do he interviews you but
you also interview him
her
and uh you
have to have some instinct about whether
this person can really help me but not
that's not so easy i was just very lucky
that the very first person
i went to was the person i stayed with
for eight years on and off
brent
you know um there's so much to learn i
think um
but through the process my guess is
her her work ethic and her
her
level of commitment
and um
and willing to to keep that promise that
she talked about earlier to herself that
if she's going to take this on and she's
going to do this
she's going to give 100
and and she did she gave 100 throughout
the whole thing she's still giving 100
this woman has been on more of these
damn panels the past year than i think
anybody and i i feel so bad every time
we ask her to do it again no you don't
no it's true though she she has an
incredible work ethic and and um and a
level of commitment that is
is is not
you don't find it often you know it's uh
it's you're swell rita
you don't think so too
i think so too that's the nice thing
about that's one of the great
rewards of therapy is that at some point
if you've been really working hard on
getting i used to call it i need to get
better
i treated myself like a sick person
and you know who always found the wrong
guys and all that kind of stuff and i
always thought of myself as getting
better
and uh
one of the great joys
of
physical therapy if it's i mean
psychotherapy uh
is to complete yourself
and to appreciate who you are
i can actually say without one iota of
embarrassment that i love myself that
doesn't mean i don't know about my fault
so that i'm unaware not at all
but the day i was able to say that to my
doctor in his presence was a red letter
day and i remember i burst into tears
and i said it's all your fault that i
love me
that makes me so happy okay i have one
last question for you so you can stop
doing these panels um
you have been asked questions in
interviews not only now promoting this
movie but your whole life uh but but
watching this movie it did really feel
like you were saying earlier like you
were digging deeper into yourself and
being unabashedly honest in a way that i
don't see that often from anybody it was
very very refreshing
did you learn anything about yourself
making this rita
oh i did it's a good question no one's
ever asked me that
here's what i learned
i learned that i'd done good
i learned that
being
respectful
to myself is more important than almost
anything
and i learned that because of my story
and it's something i would not have
really really known as well as i do now
uh having seen the documentary and i
admire that in myself i think it was
tough to do sometimes
and uh
but it proved to me
that
taking a good look at yourself
is
absolutely necessary in life
let alone when you're an actress where
it's so easy
to to uh fool yourself in so many
different ways i mean actors can be uh
very blind to who they really are
and it's probably why i would never in a
million years marry an actor
oh never one of me
marry one of me i feel the same way
no no no no i think we're difficult
people
and i think yes and i do believe that
yes we do uh
tend to think it's all about us very
often
and uh that's tough it's tough if you're
married to somebody like me
and it's tough if you're married to
someone who's not in the business
like my husband
yeah
well
i'm i'm glad you learned that because
you you are i also love you and i don't
know you so i'm glad you love yourself
because you're you're
you're easy to love and um thank you so
much everyone for your time this was a
great
pleasure of my life so thank you and i
have news for you dear you're very good
at this
i'm just a curious person i don't plan
to do it i'm getting a whole bunch of
parts and they're all latina and they're
all like they talk like this all the
time
you can always do this
well thank you thank you i i plan on
being curious forever so you did your
homework and i so appreciate that we bo
oh we all do
oh thanks i this was i it wasn't
homework it was such a pleasure to watch
this movie i i watched it before i knew
i was doing this i was so excited so
thank you
thank you thank you so much
goodbye you all
[Music]
you